i don't know
this looks like a good spot
i think this looks like a pretty good
spot to build our shelter for the night
we got tons of standing dead wood
because a forest fire came through here
and killed about 80 percent of the trees
yeah you can see the scorch marks on the
trees there's no needles on most these
pines
they're all dead
this looks promising let's see what's
under the snow make sure it's not too
lumpy
all right i think i better get the axe
out
you know i can use it
spending eight days building a log cabin
trashed my other
backpacking bow saw so i bought this one
we're gonna give it a try
and see how it does
[Music]
uh
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
we've got some really weird weather
today yeah the high is
around 35 today and we've got these high
warm winds blowing in
and look at that that looks like a rain
squall coming at us
but we can't get wet because if we do
we're going to freeze our butts off
because it's going to drop
below 20 tonight so just we've really
got to stay dry so i'm going to bust out
a tarp
and build a real quick shelter because
we cannot get wet
when we packed to come up to alaska the
weather forecast said it was going to be
like 12
degrees but here we are getting rained
on
we're just gonna hang here and stay dry
and eat some snacks
holy mackerel it is no joke raining man
we would be so smoked that we didn't
have this tarp
well the sun sets at 3 30 p.m and it's
one o'clock
right now so we are burning a lot of
daylight just sitting here waiting for
this rain to pass
not good i'll tell you what nate we're
going to sit here killing time
we're going to watch battlebots and eats
mint chocolate chip cookies
that warm wind high pressure front has
blown itself out
and the temperature is dropping pretty
quick it's getting cold
and the rain's turning into snow here we
might give it a few more minutes and we
might be able to start working again
ho ho the rain stopped all right less
than two hours before the sun sets i
better get this shelter built
i need a hustle
thank you
uh
so
you guys
uh
so
yes
didn't bring sleeping bags or tents but
i did bring a buffalo hide
there you go got two buffalo hides and
that's what me and nathan are gonna use
to sleep on
tonight and we've got the pine balls to
get us off the ground because
even with a really good insulator if
you're sitting right on that ice
takes the heat right out of you having
the pine branches will give us
an air gap between the ice and us and
give us a little bit of
softness so it's not so uh lumpy and
hard
i think nathan's just gonna snuggle in
there for a little bit
while i get the fire and the rest of the
structure put up you doing better bud
oh i am tired and hungry and it's
already four o'clock in the sun setting
i think i better just get a fire going
and start worrying about my firewood
and uh maybe bust my lights out and i
can keep working on the shelter after
dinner
[Music]
got my blast match here it's a ferris
rod on a spring you put the steel tab
down
and you make sparks and i've got a bag
of cotton balls
soaked in vaseline and these suckers
will
go up like nobody's business kind of
pull them apart a little bit
let the dry pine do its business all
this big wood is soaking wet
so we're gonna have to stick it around
the fire here and let it dry out
we're gonna fan this thing with my bin
lid
you hungry nathan good because we've got
a pretty awesome dinner ready for you
[Music]
we got this little jar with butter
rosemary and a little bit of garlic and
we're gonna put this by the fire let it
get all melty and warm for dinner we're
cooking something real special
we're grilling king crab legs over an
open fire
look at these beasts look at this
this is just one claw
holy mackerel and uh we've got a ton
of it are you you want to eat this in
addition to the king crab legs i'm
making japanese style ramen
and we got some japanese sodas to go
with that got three packs of saporo
ichiban instant ramen here
we're gonna add that to the boiling
water
got some green onions here
i'm gonna put lots of green onions in
our ramen
that is perfect
there you go ramen noodles for my nate
that's a good ramen isn't it yeah i ate
a wolf
you know what they call it in japan when
you get a second helping of ramen
what oak wadi
look at these beauties all right we're
gonna put these on the grill
frozen king crab legs are sold precooked
so all you got to do is basically just
heat them up and
enjoy them oh man they smell so good i
can see the juice
is dripping out of that one
look at that oh
this one little joint has more meat in
it than an entire blue crab
look at the size of the chunk of meat
that came out of there
holy mackerel so it's gonna get messy
folks
real messy
all right a little butter on that
whoa oh that's so good
yeah come here bud come here i'll get
you something okay
take a bite
what do you think i like it and i don't
like it
you like it and you don't like it yeah
this is one of those things that i
didn't like was a kid either
but i love it now
oh it's so good i'm gonna get every
piece of meat out of this guy
oh
this crab has more meat in his thumb
than most
most crabs have in their whole body
some of this and just
oh i am so full of crab and ramen
noodles oh it's
so good hey nathan you want a soda we're
gonna polish off this
amazing dinner with some melon flavored
japanese ramen a soda this soda is
stopped with a little glass marble
and it comes with this little plunger
and
you just squeeze that marble down and
boom
open your soda
i like melon flavored soda
so
[Music]
[Music]
well nathan's falling asleep so i'm
going to go ahead and get him ready for
bed i'm going to pull out a bunch of
hand warmers for him
these uh hand warmers have stickers on
the back and they last 12 hours so i'm
going to stick them all over nathan
on the front
oh i am tired just getting this frame up
and this one wall
taken me six hours and i had to cut down
35
dead trees these shelters are really
cozy but they are
very time consuming and take a lot of
work
oh i've had a good rest sitting here in
front of the fire but i need to get
started
on that wall so out of all the trees i
cut down today these are the only two
left so far
i need some more trees
[Music]
uh
well to say i'm sore and tired would be
a gross understatement
but i did it i've got the walls up
and it makes a huge difference it's
pushing 11 o'clock but i did it
i think i'm just going to collapse here
by the fire for a little bit i am so
tired
but one thing i've got to do before i go
to bed is melt some water i brought
three liters of water with me and we
burned through it so
i better get that done so we have it in
the morning
all right oh i am sore and it's past my
bedtime but i'm gonna sit here and enjoy
a moose's tooth root beer you know warm
campfire
before i go to bed i'll tell you what
pound for pound these balaclavas do more
than anything else to keep me warm
if you guys ever struggle with having
cold feet at night when camping
get a pair of these down booties they uh
they're super light they pack up really
small
and they keep your feet really warm i
mean they're just
basically down slippers
oh i'll tell you what this bison hide
makes a pretty woolly cocoon
this is this is pretty nice i think i'm
gonna be okay
anyway i'm getting really tired so i
think i'm gonna
call it a night and uh i'll see you guys
in the morning
well good morning it's about 7 30 a.m
and uh slept pretty well it's a little
lumpy
so i i woke up a lot and tossed and
turned a lot
but uh we did okay uh
it's really could notice when the fire
went out though
this place warms up quite well
when there's a fire so got this fire
stoked back
up and letting the place warm up and
let's sit here and
think about getting up and making
breakfast well it's almost 9
30 and the sky is going from black to
blue
we'll have the sunrise here in about an
hour so
suppose i should get up and make some
breakfast but oh
i just want to stay in my buffalo hide
all right got a bag of steel cut oatmeal
here
gonna add some milk and we're gonna add
a whole bunch of honey
oh it's warm it's tasty it's filling oh
oatmeal on a winter camp out it's pretty
hard to beat
hey nathan buddy wake up
wake up bud good morning nathan
good morning do you sleep okay
you like some warm oatmeal yeah
there you go
oh these buffalo hides are great they're
so tough and warm
well this has been an awesome shelter
i'd love to come back here and work on
this a little bit more in the future
but uh i think nathan and i are ready to
go home and see mama you ready to go
home
well thanks for watching guys we hope
you enjoyed this video if you want to
see more survival camping videos from
the outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to check out our camping
and adventure playlist i'll put a link
in the description
and don't forget to click subscribe we
put out new videos
every saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see
other great videos every saturday
morning and hit that bell button
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching